avec l'épidémie de kovy de 19 les
compétitions ne sont pas allées à leur
terme et un classement définitif a été
établi en football versailles montre à
l'année prochaine en nationale 2 en
terminant premier devant ivry de son
côté trappe termine avant dernier mais
se maintient tout de même en régionale 2
seule une formation l'équipe 2 de
versailles descendra dans la poule suite
aux décisions des instances on est
copains qu'on était mal parti en début
de saison
et puis voir même à l'arrêt du
championnat on était comme l an dernier
bon il nous restait encore quand même 7
puis rencontre donc on est les
possibilités de se maintenir mais bon à
l'issue de cette désunion
oui c'est sûr qu'on est super content et
on va pouvoir maintenant se consacrer à
une saison prochaine il a préparé au
mieux dans le championnat de première
division de district ces mots repas qui
monterait à l'année prochaine en
régionale tran terminant premier devant
hardricourt une montée historique pour
le club
personne n'a crié au scandale encore des
lieux c'était tout à fait normal et
légitime que nous manquions de terre ont
été promus en première place et en rugby
en fédérale 2 depuis trois ans plaisir
restera une année de plus dans cette
division
à la lutte pour le maintien les plaisirs
watan finalement 9e sur 12 du
championnat en disputant 17 journées la
frustration pas avoir pu gagner notre
maintien d'une manière sportive
la frustration également de ne pas voir
si on a été capable d'aller chercher
cette qualification parce qu'on était
encore dans dans la course à la 6e place
qualificative
donc voilà que c'est très frustré on
était sur une très belle dynamique de
phase retour
une division en dessous en fédérale 3
verset en course pour une éventuelle
montée en fin de saison a vu sa saison
s'achever prématurément comme toutes les
autres équipes
le rcv promu cette saison termine donc
quatrième une bonne image de la réussite
sportive de cette saison puisque un
promu aura bataillé avec avec les
premières équipes pour les places
qualificatives du championnat de france
des gal une patte qualifications mais
cela veut dire que le 8 le versailles
aura bien signé son arrivée et sa
remontée en fédérale 3 toujours en rugby
l'union rugby centre 60,18 né d'une
fusion entre le sky rugby et montigny le
bretonneux termine 5e du championnat
honneur pour sa première année
d'existence handball plaisir ce maintien
en nationale 3 en terminant 8e de sa
poule les féminines de monti le
bretonneux ment quand elle a monté après
avoir terminé la saison à la quatrième
place
une semaine avant on était deuxième on a
perdu le dernier match qui en fait nous
nous conduire nous laisse en fait en
nationale 2 pour la saison prochaine car
les compétitions étaient à compter du 12
mars ont été complètement interrompue et
on a comme andy repris le solde à ce
moment là donc ça a été ça a été un peu
surprenant je reste en fait optimiste
pour pour l'année à venir
en basket en nationale 3 masculine
trappe termine la saison à la troisième
place dans la même poule l'entente le
chesnay-versailles termine juste
derrière quatrième en football américain
la saison de deuxième division des
templiers d'elancourt s'est arrêté en
mars dernier le classement était figé
sans montée ni descente et resteront
donc en deuxième division en baseball la
saison qui réduit commencé au mois
d'avril ne se jouera finalement pas les
cougars de montigny le bretonneux ne
joueront donc aucun match cette saison